foreign
[Music]
I'm Pete Hammond and here I have three
great artists here to talk about the
movie living uh one particular scene but
also the whole movie here at any rate I
want to welcome Bill Nye the star of
living Oliver hermanus the uh director
right here and a Nobel and Booker Prize
winner and so such a distinguished
career uh Kazu ishagura who wrote the
screenplay here and let's start about
this obviously is a remake an English
language remake of uh kurosawa's uh
icaru ikuro and um tell me how it came
about was this something that you came
up with or uh how did how did the idea
to remake this and actually set it in
the same era that the original was set
in 1950 to 53. for many years I've had
this idea it was an ambition by not not
to you know participate in it but to
actually see some they do a do a
beautiful English version of kurosaurus
ikuru ikuru was a very important movie
for me from when I was about 10 11 12.
yeah I watched it whenever I could and I
think it it became almost like an
obsession as I was growing up that the
message that it had about how you
approached life but it's only about uh
you know 15 years ago that I started to
think it'll be wonderful
if if that somebody would actually use
that material but also marry it with
with a whole bunch of stuff about
englishness and and a kind of England
that had kind of vanished you know
sometime after the second world war but
nevertheless it represented something
that's still Universal about human
nature and so that that was my initial
impasse things only really clicked for
me when I had this kind of epiphany
moment I thought if Bill Nye I didn't
know Bill at this point if Bill Nye
could do it you know it would actually
be perfect it would be the Gateway into
this kind of englishness now let's set
up the story here a little bit to lead
into the scene that we're examining as
part of the scene at the Academy of
course he finds out Mr Williams that
he's going to die within six months he
has lived the same life for 20 years
since his wife died everything has been
the same same routine suddenly the title
of the movie comes into play here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
the important thing about this film is
that although it is a it is about
somebody who gets uh you know a very
gloomy
diagnosis
it's actually a film about not not about
diet it is about living right yeah in a
way that the the death sentence from
cancer is a kind of a McGuffin if you
like yeah
I think it's actually possible to to do
this movie without the uh diagnosis I
mean you just need something
that that makes that question very
urgent so what is actually important in
life if you've only got a limited amount
of time and the horrible truth is with
all of us only got a limited amount of
time we all think we're going to live
forever but actually you know it we've
all been given some sort of death
sentence by by our condition uh that
we're human
so so you know what how do you make
um your life meaningful how do you how
do you gain some sense of satisfaction
why the original Curacao meant so much
to me and why I wanted you know our
movie to to say something very strongly
in this about this question was that I
think it is actually subtly and
crucially different to to the message of
say A Christmas Carol or It's a
Wonderful Life
you know these these kinds of stories uh
try and provide an answer to that
question they had
um you're either completely change
yourself from being this kind of
bad person to a wonderful person
overnight and then you know that your
life becomes meaningful or or you might
think your your life is pathetic but
actually you don't realize that you're
inadvertently doing wonderful things to
all the people around you these are the
two kind of messages those movies give
and there's there are long Traditions
that come out of them ikiru says
something else different it said you
know you can have a tiny life a very
humble hum drum life but just with a
little bit of an effort you can tip that
from being this kind of shell of a life
to something quite magnificent and
heroic you can just stay the person you
are you can just play the hand that life
has dealt with you so
um for me that you know that that's why
this film is called living it's a
celebratory film about a guy who's dying
and we see that in this scene here which
goes to the seaside outside of London
and he goes out there and uh there's a
exotic dancers and stuff going on and he
meets this guy
um Sutherland played by Tom Burke and uh
tell us about that and why that scene
was so important and the way you filmed
it too because it's quite dark in a lot
of ways too as we see him emerge from
almost the darkness I I noticed with the
cinematography yes uh I the idea of
Sutherland was that he was going to be
this this man of a younger generation
just like one generation
um Don from Williams who just lived his
life on a different track you'd lived
his life kind of just not doing the
things that Williams had done the sort
of servitude that Williams demonstrates
as a man and it just sort of never the
way he married never really had anyone
to worry about but himself you know
really he traveled to most of Europe had
a life full of sort of decadence and
self-interest uh and so this man is a
man of the place and time and Williams
Bill's character has assumed this is his
first assumption with the knowledge of
his own death that he's going to just
sort of take all his money take out of
the bank he's going to go to the coast
and he's going to have what he imagines
to be fun but he doesn't really know
what fun is he's never only as he says
to Southern like you know I don't know
how and he's just lucked out meeting
this man who you know if you've got some
money and free time he's the guy you
want to you know go out with and he sort
of tries different things with Williams
takes him around you these all these
little horns but by the time we get to
this particular scene you know
Sutherland is getting a little bit
desperate to sort of find something to
really keep Williams interested
um and he's a really really passed out
he's so tired probably just had too much
to drink and then there's this Pang
death arrives death comes knocking and
it's the first time we really see that
with Williams
um and he has to run outside and then
there's this Moment of Truth between
them which is completely unspoken and I
really wanted Bill to emerge from the
dark although I kept sending you further
and further back I remember to keep
going but I'll keep going I love that I
thought that was a really effective to
be Beyond the Lights because I wanted
you to come out of the Dark of the sort
of like the sort of real tonal change
and bull does it so extraordinarily
because it was you know three o'clock in
the morning it was really cold and I
just wet balls just you could just read
everything on his face and having Tom
was just one is one of Bill's you know
good friends and it was just a lovely
moment between them with Tom just sort
of being the perfect person who could be
you know he takes his hat off because it
sort of he gets it he reads the moment
this is because it needs to be this
moment of respect that a man's life this
is mortality that they're facing
together and the night is definitely
done yeah and and but that's so key and
that's so key for you as an actor
getting into this character that moment
I would imagine too yes and I remember
that Tom after he'd taken the role he
said that one of the I mean there were
many reasons why he wanted to be in the
movie but one of the reasons was this
scene he that that in fact that beat
that moment
he'd identified that as uh as a key
moment for him as Oliver says you know
Williams has never had what he's heard
about this thing called a good time you
know what I mean and he goes and and I
find it very moving that he goes to
Brighton
brightness it's a sort of period it's
where you went to have a good time you
know so you went to the coast and I'm
sure there are equivalents in every
country
yeah quote but uh Las Vegas yeah exactly
it's like he went to Vegas
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die in baby
except it's Brighton which is even
sadder no disrespect to Las Vegas but um
yeah so uh you know and he sees this guy
who he figures he thinks maybe he looks
like a guy who's who knows what a good
time is you know it's very moving that
he and he shows him the money and says
all this cash and says you know
um if I would you help me spend this
money I mean it's an incredibly nice
Reckless innocent kind of uh thing to
ask somebody that you know you don't
know in a cafe and that's the key
motivation when he goes back to London
and suddenly you brought up Christmas
Carol it's suddenly like you know he's
never Scrooge the character is not that
but suddenly it's a different person
yeah yeah I mean it I suppose you can
decorate that that he's had this shock
of having this diagnosis so he kind of
auditions the obvious
answers to you know what what what how
how do you can live your life to the
full in the time you've got and so at
the scene we are talking about is the
moment Hedonism kind of fails the
audition
um and I I don't think you kind of
rejects it in a flippant or um even an
angry way you know that uh and this is
what I like about the interplay between
uh Ben and Tom Burke There's real
respect I mean and and that that's there
in the original Curacao as well unless I
filmed an IQ would have actually made
the Tom Burke character somebody uh
nastier or much more loose uh much more
repulsive so that it's easier for for in
our case you know the Williams character
to reject the person who represents the
hedonistic solution but
um no the Tom Burke character is is very
subtle and very decent and and they do
form a kind of friendship and I feel in
that moment when they look at each other
you know they understand something of
each other is predicament you know
there's a kind of camaraderie and
understanding
and you know I like the way bill I mean
I don't know if it's your ideal Bill's
idea but when he emerges after that he
he Taps Tom Burke on the shoulder almost
reassuringly you know
um it's almost to say you know one day
you'll be in my position as well we're
all in this together because that is the
moment when
um Tom Burke
not only realizes that Williams is dying
but that death is real I mean the
reality of death
really hits him for the first time and
they're in something together so
um so the the way you know where you
directed it where you played it I think
it just makes it a much more Rich scene
than than oh you know I tried Hedonism
it doesn't work I I have to look for
something else I mean it's much deeper
than that it was on the page on your
page but what he brought to it and your
cinematographer of course that's Jamie
Ramsay of course yes yes I mean we work
really closely together and uh we
discussed that scene quite a lot because
it was this this fun idea of fun idea um
of having this tanned you know happiness
kind of all around like particularly the
inside of the tent you know lots of warm
lighting this is a really fun time for
people and having this there are these
lights outside above Tom's head as well
so this challenge of lighting something
that is the sort of womb of Happiness on
the seaside and then having to sort of
bring bull out of the dark and you know
I added this sort of droning sound of
the ocean as well the sort of repetitive
sound um and it all goes very quiet
um I think it's just a one it's like an
amazing opportunity for for me as a
director when you work with two actors
who can do a scene in this zero dialogue
but they are so they're such clear beats
in what they're doing there is there's a
level of communication going on like Tom
noticing him something's wrong seeing
Bull's hand bull hiding his hand that
reaction to that Tom taking off his hat
building deciding that he's going to go
back inside and how he touches Tom so
that's that's a that's communication and
you know it was just I mean honestly I
just put the camera there and Jamie put
the lights down we just kind of watched
them do it well it's remarkable it's
remarkable in the context of the movie
living too so I hope if you haven't seen
it yet uh this will encourage you to I
bet it does and uh if you have seen it
it's so great to hear how it all turned
out and the movie so thank you all for
joining us at scene at the Academy thank
you thank you all right